well doc you can't save everybody jelly
baby yeah they're not actually jelly
babies are actually licorice that were
that were sent to me by one of my
subscribers for my birthday they get it
very nice thank you I'm that weirdo who
likes licorice anyways I just had to cut
out a whole bunch of chew action the pup
that in my mouth so Doctor Who list time
for this month and this was one where
the patreon supporters got to help me
decide to give him some options for
various lists that I could do this month
the one they selected was my list of the
top ten people that the doctor couldn't
save as is usually the case with me I am
restricting this to new modern era
Doctor Who because I've seen all of that
and I have I still have too many
sizeable gaps of my classic knowledge to
be able to integrate that so just a
couple things about this list it is what
it sounds like these were people who did
not make it through the stories that
they appeared in the doctor could not
save them I am excluding regular
companions because one could argue that
bill might qualify or possibly even rose
they were both saved in a way but
neither by the doctor but I'm not
counting them and also a character who
was in contention who I decided to not
include is Adelaide Brooke because the
reason she died is not because the
doctor failed to save her
that was for other very different
reasons so that established who actually
made the list I'm gonna start with my
pick for number 10 bannakaffalatta and
no there's no nickname it's Bonica
Velata so this is the tiny red spiky
character cyborg character for
voyage of the Damned first of all I mean
immediately visually memorable also
named pretty tang memorable as well as
long and convoluted and sort of tricky
to get our get around is saying it
smoothly is so that's points in his
favor also pretty endearing as a
character he's you know he's got a lot
of sort of doubts and fears but he he
stands up he he you know he makes the
movie he makes the sacrifice to save
others and it's one of the more
triumphant moments of the show there are
there's a surprising number of character
deaths in that particular episode I
don't think all of them work his does
the he goes the extra mile the doctor
couldn't save him but he went out in
style number 9 Jade so going way back
second episode of new who the end of the
world so this is our lovely lady from
the forest of cheem who has blessed with
air from the doctor's lungs and seems
quite taken with that normally the whole
like characters generally female
occasions be kind of new towards the
doctor I really don't care for but there
was something about a tree like him
blowing on her and her how intimate like
that's weird enough that works for me
and I really do gotta love it so she was
also quite she showed a lot of strength
as a as a character and then I actually
like by Mike have a lot says she does
ultimately choose to sacrifice herself
for others for the doctor so that he can
save more people but she also had a
wonderful softness to her and actually a
really great dynamic with Eccleston
that's usually the hallmark of any good
characters if they have a really good
dynamic going on with the lead so that
you know you you still remember them
even at even if they only appeared in
one episode number 8 another character
from voyage of the Damned
Astrid Perth I think for some people she
will be higher on their own personal
list I don't doubt it's like I do like
Astrid I feel like some people have a
lot higher degree of affection for her
than I do but I do enjoy her as a
character she is that that person who
just went out to try and find adventure
not like save the universe just have a
bit of fun and that's the kind of person
that the doctor kind of tends to have an
attraction to she's not running away
from anything she's running to she
doesn't even know whatever the universe
has in store for her and that sort of
attitude is very doctor asking you can
see why that appeals to him and again
the dynamic between the Tenth Doctor and
Astrid works quite well she's she's
sweet she's endearing you want the best
for her and she doesn't get it cuz the
doctor cannot save her not completely he
mean arguably he kind of does but what
he saves is not complete I I don't think
you could argue otherwise number 7 the
stewardess so from midnight we never
learned her name and in many ways she is
kind of in the background until towards
the end of this story this amazing a god
I love midnight it's such a good episode
and she's in the back dismissed
ignored not taken seriously by anyone
else there but watching what's going on
and coming to a much better
understanding than anyone else in the
room and knowing what's going on better
than they do because she's been paying
attention
she makes the leap and again sacrifices
herself and saves the doctor and no one
even knew her name but she she stood up
and she did what she knew was right not
only in the face of her own death but in
absolute defiance of everyone around her
and it's it's a character that we never
got detailed depth on because that's not
the point actually the point that we
don't know that much about her kind of
is the point but she she left a mark
nonetheless number six mrs. Moore I have
very mixed feelings about the two part
of that introduced the Cybermen into new
who however I don't have very mixed
feelings about the character of mrs.
Moore basically the tech head for this
little sort of ragtag resistance group
headed by the alternate universe Mickey
and Jake and it's I I love her I feel
like she's got one of the best lines in
this two-parter you know yelling at them
to get in the Benz the slowest getaway
in history and like she doesn't take
crap but she also has her moment of kind
of opening up to the doctor and telling
him more about herself than she and
generally less people know any more
because of safety concerns people can't
know about her who she is where she came
from what her history is but she shares
those moments with the doctor while
still maintaining you know that really
um tough side as well you know having on
Handa an EMP bomb to take out a Cyberman
and unfortunately to be zapped by
another one that came in behind her she
was and and she gets a nice little
additional send-off because the doctor
having learned her actual name and that
she does have family be sure to tell
Jake hey find her family make sure that
they know what she did and that's she
deserved that send-off number five
father Octavian so this is from the
two-parter and time of the angels and
flesh and stone' and yeah look yeah
Jorah Mormont I he's an actor with a
really great presence and he has that
here and he has a
wonderful sense of authority and even
though the doctor is undercutting and
undermining him at every step of the way
he doesn't feel like he is weak and
impotent in the face of the doctors so
like to make a comparison to say the
military commander in something like
let's go with the Sontaran two-parter
from series for whoever was sort of
having you know the doctor is dismissive
oven doesn't take him seriously and the
guy himself is coming
oh you can't you can't take him
seriously father Octavian the doctor is
dismissive of him you know at one point
saying well that's the church for you no
offense you know very off handedly and
father are taking his offense very well
very much taken if you don't mind you
know he he is out of his depth
the doctors better equipped for this
than he is but he never feels
incompetent he feels like the guy you
would want to send in if you didn't have
the doctor there and he doesn't feel
useless and superfluous because the
doctor is there and again a great sense
of presence to him great line deliveries
and a pretty pretty strong closeout and
like when he when he knows he's gonna
die in the dark saying I wish I had
known you better he says I think you
knew me at my best
that was good stuff number four possibly
a little bit of a weird choice but you
know it just works for me mr. Jefferson
from another two part of funny house how
the two partners when done well really
give me some affection for these
characters so he is from the impossible
planet and the Satan pit he was the head
of security we don't know what it was
but we know something went on with his
wife the Beast needles him over that and
but he is very focused he's on the job
he doesn't he he doesn't take his eye
off his duty to protect and all the
human beings that are under his care
yeah at the same time he doesn't come
across like a robot he has a sense of
personality he has a rapport with
everyone else so he feels like a person
but a professional he knows what he's
due
but he is not you know just all business
all the time he can have you know little
small moments he can be appreciative for
everything that was done to try and save
him even though he knows he's not gonna
make it and it's it's just these kinds
of security characters can often just be
boring and wrote in generic and he
wasn't I I mean I love the entire
supporting cast of this one book because
he's the one who did well he's not the
only one who didn't make it screw didn't
make it Toby didn't make it but they
didn't leave the impression on me that
mr. Jefferson did so he gets the spot
number three Rita from the god complex
I remember thinking and at the time that
I saw it the first time that she was
like one of the first characters that
were like I really strongly felt like
boy she could have been a companion and
it would have been really good she's a
terrific rapport with Smith she is
analytical she's thoughtful she is
determined she is just a she's a good
person she's a rounded character she has
terrific rapport with Smith and she just
isn't gonna make it and when it sinks in
for you that she is not going to survive
this it's like oh come on it's oh it's
tough
she was just ugh a great she's the kind
of character that like in some ways he
gave me flashbacks to Sally Sparrow like
I would watch you in something that the
doctor didn't even appear in I would
watch you she was just engaging and and
strong-willed and just held my attention
on the screen and she also died so it
goes to left and for my number two slot
some may call it a cheat I say that's my
list I can do it how I want ah but I do
actually consider this to be a separate
character from from someone who wouldn't
have qualified for this so
victorian-era governess Clara yeah I
count her as a separate character from
Clara amongst other reasons I liked her
better than Clara like immediately I
liked her I got such a sense of this
character right from the get-go she is
you know working at a posh home being
the governess to these kids
but she's rough-and-tumble she hides her
accent I'm immediately getting
personality and a sense of history and
her place in the world and like this
immediate impression of a full person
which I never I mean I'm not gonna say I
never got but it took me like a season
and a half before I felt like I
understood the Clara we actually had on
the show as much as I understood this
version of Clara I was immediately
intrigued by her I like that she doesn't
feel like a woman out of time in the in
the sense that like oh well she might as
well be from modern days like well no
but she just thinks well she's
forward-thinking for a time but still of
her time and the again the dynamic what
the doctor is terrific she has the sense
of hey this could be fun and I I am
always gonna wish that she had been the
version that had traveled with the
doctor
I said I'm the Clara we had but she
doesn't think that number one spot
because if we're talking about
characters that the doctor couldn't save
there is and always was and could only
be one name at the top of this list
Vincent Vincent and the doctor is an
episode that I didn't appreciate when I
first saw it and every year that goes by
I appreciate it more and more and more
and the depiction of Vincent van Gogh
and his battle with depression because
that's what the episode is about he's
fighting an invisible monster that no
one else can see but might but could
possibly kill him and the doctor does
somebody and the thing
I think the doctor knows that he's that
what they're doing is not ultimately
going to save Vincent I think he knows
that Amy doesn't know that Amy doesn't
afraid of look all you can do is try and
add to someone's pile of good things
because that's the nature of depression
a good day doesn't cure you of
depression even some concrete firm
reassurance that who you are and what
you do matters doesn't make depression
go away Vincent could not be saved by
the doctor because Vincent could not be
saved by anybody this was going to
consume him always and no matter what
but he could still have a really good
day with the doctor and with Amy and for
that he is to me the best character that
the doctor could not save that's my list
of ten what are your thoughts who would
you put on your list for characters to
meet this criteria whatever it is drop
slumming down the comments let's talk
about a whole bunch of stuff to do
buttons links I had my birthday already
but I do still have the Amazon wishlist
link down in the description in case you
want to send me a belated thing I'll
stop at the end of March I promise but
that'll be it for now folks so check all
those links out below there's other ones
even besides that you know there's links
to various of the things I do social
media my peel box
blah blah blah blah blah check it out
down in the description or you know it's
okay if you don't because at the end of
the day you're the council I just run
the meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]